[Música]
la economía en directo américa de france
24 ya está conmigo en el estudio daniel
hablando onda ni vamos a hablar de los
precios de la energía que siguen
impulsando la inflación en europa es que
nadie se salva de todo este contexto
mundial que estamos viviendo no diseño
raúl muy buenos días feliz martes el
índice de precios al consumidor está
subiendo a un ritmo que ya se acerca a
los dos dígitos en los 27 países que
conforman la unión europea con alzas que
impactan más que todo a los países
bálticos que comparten tasas de
inflación de alrededor del 20 por ciento
según la oficina de estadísticas casi la
mitad de esa inflación recorta en junio
se debió por supuesto al aumento de los
precios de la energía y el segundo
factor son los alimentos más costosos
ahora veamos cómo ha sido es el
crecimiento de los precios desde que
inició la guerra a comienzos de este año
los precios se han venido disparando
venían creciendo al 5 6% en enero antes
de la guerra y ya están a punto de
duplicar esa tasa de aumento con un 96
por ciento interanual en junio bueno y
usted mejor que yo lo sabe porque está
alza de los precios en europa tiene una
aplicación / seguramente muchas otras
pero hay una y es el descenso del
suministro de gas en rusia desde las
rocas y tiene el nombre propio este alza
de precios del continente ha venido
buscando nuevas fuentes de hidrocarburos
pero siguen siendo altamente
dependientes según cada país de hecho el
gasoducto nord stream 1 el más grande
transportador de gas natural ruso hacia
europa se encuentra en mantenimiento
como ya lo hemos informado y debería
entrar de nuevo en funcionamiento el
próximo jueves pero las autoridades ya
dan por hecho que esto no va a ocurrir
en este sentido ante un corte total del
suministro el fondo monetario
internacional estimó este martes que los
países de europa del este y europa
central van a ver un efecto devastador
con caídas de su producto interno bruto
de hasta el 6% aproximadamente esto
también dependiendo del país en alemania
es del 3% en españa es el 1 por ciento y
en francia el 1 por ciento dependiendo
de cappa claro danny fijamos un lado
europeo para vernos a nuestra región de
américa latina y el caribe porque hay un
nuevo paro de transportadores en perú a
qué se debe bueno pues a los precios de
los costos inglés como ha sucedido en
las últimas semanas y es que la
defensoría del pueblo reportó el lunes
que hubo bloqueos de carreteras en la
sureña región de ayacucho también
concentraciones de manifestantes esto en
el primer día del paro indefinido de
transportadores de carga y agricultores
por lo que veníamos diciendo el alza del
precio de los combustibles también de
los fertilizantes y es que este país
tiene la gasolina más cara de
latinoamérica según un reporte de la
agencia bloomberg lo que hace que los
peruanos busquen otras alternativas para
abastecer sus autos son nuestro
corresponsable de lima francisco
zacarías nos amplía la información
luis alcántara fabrica muebles de acero
y en sus ratos libres es taxista sin
embargo debido al elevado precio de la
gasolina ha decidido modificar su carro
a gas natural vehicular para poder
seguir generando ingresos como conductor
para todos los 40 críticas por eso ya
con cambiando legal la mayoría se borra
para algunos que también viven del taxi
no my peor debe ser yo que tengo un
trabajo ahí te iba a ir también
batallando ya que poco a poco ya la que
todo esto pasión así como louis muchos
peruanos se están recurriendo a la
conversión de sus vehículos de gasolina
a gas natural aprovechando un
financiamiento estatal sin intereses eso
permitirá a los usuarios un ahorro
mensual de cerca del 70%
según la asociación de estaciones de
servicio en el último año los precios de
las gasolinas de 91 95 octanos han
subido a 35 y 47 por ciento
respectivamente las causas del
sobreprecio impuestos elevados una
onerosa cadena de comercialización y los
altos costos de producción de las
refinerías subieron el combustible sube
todo porque todo se transporta
con algo que gaste combustible y acá
pagamos los sueldos millonarios de los
funcionarios de petroperú y sus coimas
en todo lo que compra eso es lo que
estamos pagando por eso pagamos de
combustible más caro de sudamérica según
los analistas el elevado precio de la
gasolina repercutirá negativamente a
largo plazo en la economía peruana ese
aumento muy fuerte del precio de los
combustibles
obviamente está haciendo que la
inflación suba fuertemente y golpee más
a los que menos tienen por qué porque
los sectores de bajos ingresos más del
50 por ciento de su gasto diario los
destinan a alimentos y combustibles el
estado ha destinado más de 630 millones
de dólares en exoneraciones tributarias
y subsidios en un intento de combatir el
alza de los combustibles no obstante
diversos agentes económicos prevén que
durante julio los precios seguirán altos
y que la inflación alcanzará el 9 por
ciento
bueno dar muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información de
economía nos vemos o más adelante en
nuestra segunda hora por supuesto con
más nos vamos directo hasta cuando